hello my name is Catherine Kwan and I'm
a developer advocate on the developer
relations team here at Google today I'll
be talking about Google Play services
for those of you who don't know what it
is it's a way for us to provide new API
s to developers on a regular basis that
will work on devices running the latest
operating system all the way back to
Gingerbread it contains great API such
as location games wallet G+ and much
much more
you can leverage all of these to create
amazing apps for your users to use these
API s you can access them through the
Google Play services app which is
delivered to users devices through
Google Play and updated automatically
with the most recent release of the app
we're moving to a new model for how
developers like you can interact more
consistently with these services don't
worry though if you've previously
integrated with Google Play services
nothing changes for your existing apps
in the wild the binary interface to the
Google Play services app remains the
same so previously compiled apps will
continue to work in today's step byte
I'll cover why we need this change what
it is and how to implement it and step
through an example together with you so
let's begin with the basics to use all
the great API is provided by the Google
Play services app you need to first open
up a client connection to that process
to do this you include the Google Play
services SDK in your app and call in to
the SDK to setup the connection now
there used to be a different client for
each service such as the plus client
games client app state client and so on
to use three services you would have to
create three clients and manage
independent connections with slightly
different nuances
fortunately with this new and simplified
interaction model you'll only need a
single Google API client to connect to
the Google Play services app when you
setup the client you specify it
whichever api's you want to use this
greatly improves the developer
experience because you only have one
client to worry about connecting and
handling callbacks for let's talk about
how to implement it by seeing some
examples of how you would initialize the
Google API
and this shows you how to add the wallet
API and specify an account
this shows the plus API and scope
this shows the drive API in scope and
now the real difference is that now you
can add multiple API s and scopes easily
which is a huge win in terms of saving
you development time and complexity so
once you have initialized a client where
the api is you need you have to connect
and implement callbacks with a single
Google API client as seen here after you
have a connected Google API client how
do you access the methods in the API we
can look at the case of games as an
example the previous model involves
calling into the games client as the
main entry point to get things like
achievements and leaderboards but that
is now being deprecated so should we
call it on Google API client because
that's a replacement well we can't
because it's not coupled to any service
and we don't want it to know about all
the methods that each service could
potentially provide instead the answer
is to use the new entry points that
we've created in the games case the main
entry point is now the game's class
which offers static methods to read or
write data you can access game
achievements through the game side
achievements class or leaderboards
through the game's dot leaderboards
class and so on every time you make it
call to an API you must pass the Google
API client object as well this serves as
a reminder that you need an open
connection to the Google Play services
app in order for the request to be
handled for more detail you can check
out the documentation or sample games
apps using the provided link now after
you call an API we've standardized it so
that you get a pending result back
pending result is typed so that you can
expect the answer that you're waiting
for to be of type result you can wait
synchronously for the result as seen
here or you can set an async callback to
notify you later when the result is
ready result is an interface that the
service is used to return you the data
you've requested and it has a get status
method the status object tells you
information about whether or not the
result was successful and uses a
standard set of status codes then you
can proceed and use the result to review
everything we went over let's walk
through an example we are fetching the
visible people in a user's G+ circles
which can be useful for example to
create a social experience in an app
first we set up the Google API client
and set the plus API scope and
connection callbacks then we implement
the callback methods for connection
succeeded suspended or failed the
connection could fail because it
requires user intervention for example
to choose an account then an intent
would be returned in the connection
result and you should allow the user to
resolve the problem and connect again
next we call connect and disconnect on
the Google API client as soon as a
connection is successful we can fetch
the information our app needs by calling
a static method in the API which is plus
people API download visible and we pass
in the Google API client on the pending
result that gets returned we set a
callback because we want the result
asynchronously in the callback we will
receive a load people result which is of
type result so we can get the status and
check the status code is successful if
all is well then we can obtain the list
of people that we're looking for from
the result to see the full example go to
the list visible People activity Java
class in the samples in the SDK in
conclusion we are moving towards a
consistent model of how to interact with
Google Play services see the
documentation for more details existing
services like games app state wallet and
G+ have already converted to the new
model and more will be coming soon new
services like chromecast and drive are
already working with a Google API client
so try out Google Play services day and
see how it can enhance your app thank
you for watching and see you next time